お兄ちゃん社長今日はパズそうですこの回転数を買ったんだ
走ってる人は多いかもしれないが僕はのれるほど良いがしない相場ずに乗ってはクーバ
に乗っても z 煌歳のても空気になっても欄に乗ってもよりもご用意しない無敵だ
そこで俺は考えたらこの回転椅子よく言われる事が回りすぎと気持ち悪くなるってよく
言われるよね
今回はそれを
が実際にすることもあって転生してみようと思うさて僕を
気持ちを楽することができるかなーなんだよこの海テニスぐるぐる回って気持ち潤とか
言う人がたまにいるんです
あいつら本当にそう思ってるのかこれにある理解できないんですよ動く系で気持ちよく
なったことがないんでぶっちゃけねこれによってねずっと回転死んでも多分強弱なら
ない
[音楽]
ブービー4泊しました
まあ予定
はかないん
入ったことないも来ることがズってねーしてるんだ
4スポーツを張ってみましょうどんな動き出した
お気がした過ごせますすみんね
voodoo
are you on
me
絶対履かないからなん
は can
yuha
持った
なんかもう目が回るません
ッ気持ち悪いとは別だからそのまま生き masa
[音楽]
ren
うううっ
[音楽]
ええええええ
これが乗り物酔いか
the source しないとか買ったタイマー用具んですかありがとうございます
うん